الانجاب مساله مصريه واحيانا يصبح مساله
جدليه كما هي الحال في قصتنا اليوم الجدل
القديم جديد هل ينجب اكثر من يجني اكثر
ولو ان الارقام تظهر ان من يجني اكثره ومن
يتريق اكثر ربما وعيا منه المسؤوليات في
الكويت تجدد الجدل حول هذا الموضوع بعد ان
ابدت المحاميه الكويتيه مريم المؤمن رايها
بكل صراحه وقالت لنبويه داخل المحدود
عليهم ان يتجنب انجاب الكثير من الاطفال
معطيه الحريه لذلك لاصحاب الدخل العالي
مريم المؤمن اشارت لانها لاقت هجوما كبيره
وتنمر عليها رغم ان هذا الراي اذا خرج عن
رجل لا يواجه بمثل هذا الهجوم
[موسيقى]
مره تكلمت ايضا عن اللي يبيعون
بالرقي وهذا تكلمت عنهم بانه اذا انت كنت
يعني على قد حالك لا تجيب وايد يا حالو
يعني هذول برقبتك ما قلت لك ما قلت لك لا
تتزوج هذه سنه الحياه ولكن فكر بعقلك انك
تحد ما عجبهم الكلام
[موسيقى]
يعني انا مثلا مثال يعني ما بخلف ما عندي
اطفال بالمره ربنا سبحانه وتعالى اراد
لاني انا اكون من غير اطفال بس انما لو
اراد ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
واحد اثنين ثلاثه هو عطاء رباني وربنا
سبحانه وتعالى بيرزقنا وبيرزقهم يعني
اكيد كريم
الولد يكون ياخذ حقه من التربيه يعني لازم
يكون في فاصل من الاولاد يعني حتى ياخذوا
حقهم من التربيه والتعليم والصحه
[موسيقى]
دكتور يعني عديد من الدول تنادي بتنظيم
النسل يعني لكن الملفت في مجتمعاتنا خصوصا
العربيه حيث الكثافه السكانيه العاليه
الدخل دخل الفرد منخفض هناك يعني نسبه
انجاب عالي كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك اجتماعيه
يمكن تفسير ذلك دينيا اولا وليس اجتماعيا
لانه هم يربطون دائما
الانجاب وكثره الانجاب هو نوع من المباهه
وهو نوع من العزوه والكثره والرزق من الله
سبحانه وتعالى وهم يربطونها دائما بالدين
لهذا السبب اي اي انسان سواء كان عالم
مفكر
يتحدث في التحديد هذا سوف يواجه من قبل
المجتمعات العربيه بشكل عنيف جدا احنا مع
التنظيم احنا مع المباعد بين المواليد نحن
مع الحكمه نحن مع توفير كل العيش اللائق
والسليم للمجتمع والدول ايضا كمان ولكن
نحن لسنا مع ان يقال كلمه تحديد الخطوره
انه دائما
المجتمعات تربط باي مناداه تتعلق بالنسل
او بالانجاب بانها هذه مؤامره على الدول
العربيه وهذه مؤامره على الانجاب طيب
اسماء بالحديث عن حق الاولاد في التربيه
والصحه والتعليم ما رايك بالمقوله الشعبيه
اللي تقول كل طفل يجيب رزقه وبركته معه
الا اما ده اثبتت انها واقعيه او عكس ذلك
والله ربنا يرزق الجميع يا حبيبتي بس هذا
الكلام يعني اوكي ربنا هو الرازق واحنا
مؤمنين وبنعرف الكلام هذا صح لكن الاطفال
بحاجه لتعليم بحاجه لصحه بحاجه الى اشباع
عاطفيه يعني اذا كان الواحد عنده عشر
ابناء كيف بدي يلحق يقعد معاهم ينصحهم
يوجههم ويربيهم ثاني شيء يعني دائما انا
بحكي عن لما نحكي عن تنظيم الاسره ما
بنحكي عن تحديد الاسره لما رغيف الخبز بدك
تقسمه على الاثنين اكيد بيكون مشبع انا ما
بدك تسمع على اربعه بيكون اخف شويه لما
بدك تقف معي على سته شو بدهم ياكلوا
فاحنا بنحكي ماشي الارزاق بيد الله لكن
الله سبحانه وتعالى اعطانا العقل المميز
يعني في الزمنات يعني كثير كانوا مثلا
اهالينا ظروف اهالينا بتختلف عن ظروفنا
احنا وظروفنا احنا بتختلف عن ظروف ابنائنا
وظروف ابناءنا بتختلف عن ظروف احفادنا
لذلك نحن اللازم نجار الزمان يحسن التعليم
مكلف بالصحه مكلفه الابناء بدهم اشباح
عاطف وهذا شيء جدا مهم نرجع يعني الاستاذه
مريم لما حكت ان يعني الفقير لازم يحدد او
ينظم بينما الوضع المادي مش مشكله انا
باقول لا الجهتين لازم يكون في تنظيم
اسره لازم يكون يعني حتى الامور كثير
الاطفال بحاجتها مش بس التعليم ولكن الصحه
ولا ولا هذول الاشياء الاساسيه